First I'm going to talk about networks in general. The
internet is just a special kind of network. There are lots
of different ways to define a network. We are going to
use quite a precise definition. So we are going to define
a network as a group of entities. And entities could be
people, they could be computers, they could be organizations, they could
be governments, that can communicate, even though they're not all directly
connected. So here's an example to show what that definition means.
So we have Alice. And we have Bob.
And Alice and Bob know each other, and can
talk to each other. The way they talk, we can
call the channel. That could be just talking in
person. That could be talking over a telephone. We're going to
say that just this is not enough to be
a network. This is just two people having a conversation.
If we had the second scenario, we'll say we have
Alice, Bob and Charlie. And Alice can communicate with Bob.
Bob can communicate with Charlie. And Charlie can communicate
with Alice. But they can do all this directly. They're
all directly connected. If Alice wants to talk to
Charlie, well, she has a direct link to Charlie. She
doesn't need to use Bob. There's no way to
communicate other than across these direct links. So even in
this case where there are three people who can all
communicate we're still going to say that's not a network.
Many people would call both of these networks. We're going
to use a somewhat more precise definition where neither of these
will be considered a network. What will be considered a
network is this third example and in the third example we
have three nodes. We have Alice, Bob, and Charlie let's
say. They're the three people but now Alice is not directly
connected to Charlie. But there's a way that Alice can
send a message to Charlie. And she can send the message,
because Bob will forward the message for
her. Once the message goes through two hops,
to make it so two people are not
directly connected, can communicate. And maybe Charlie can
also send messages back to Alice. Then we call it a network. So that's going to
be our definition. There has to be at least three entities and there has to be
a way that entities that are not
directly connected can still communicate. So to see
that you understand that definition of a
network and maybe also know a little bit
of world history we're going to have a
quiz. So here are the possible answers. Ten
years old, 30 years old, 100 years old, 1000 years old, or over 3000 years old.